- When we looked at glycolysis
and the conversion of Pyruvate
to Acetyl-CoA and then the
Krebs or the Citric acid Cycle,
we were sometimes directly producing ATPs
but we were also doing a lot
of reduction of NAD to NADH,
and we later said that NADH,
that that can later be oxidized, too,
and that energy from that oxidation,
that energy that's
released from the electrons
can be used to actually create ATP,
and NADH is the main character here,
but there are other
coenzymes that are involved,
like coenzyme Q, and you
see that right over here.
And what I want to talk
about in this video
is the process by which we
actually are able to produce ATP
from the oxidation of these coenzymes,
and that process is what we call
Oxidative Phosphorylation.
Oxidative, Oxidative Phosphorylation.
Now the main player, when we're talking
about cellular respiration
and Oxidative Phosphorylation,
is NADH.
NADH, in the process of being oxidized
to NAD,
so it gets oxidized to N...
it gets oxidized to NAD,
which has a positive charge,
I often call it NAD+, but let's
think about what this says.
If we just look at this
reaction from the point of view
of NADH being oxidized, remember,
oxidation is losing electrons,
so NAD+, and then you're gonna have
plus a hydrogen proton
plus, you're going to have two electrons,
plus two electrons.
So this is what's happening when NADH
is being oxidized into NAD,
so this is Oxidation right over here.
Let me do this in another color.
So this is Oxidation, and
this process of Oxidation,
if these electrons get the
appropriate acceptor molecule,
it can release a lot of energy,
and the eventual acceptor
of those electrons,
and I can show the corresponding
reduction reaction,
is we have two electrons,
two electrons plus two hydrogen protons,
or really, just two
protons, a hydrogen nucleus
is just a proton, it
doesn't have a neutron
for the main isotope of hydrogen.
So two protons
plus half of an oxygen molecule yielding,
you put all of these
two, all of these three,
all of these things
together, I should say,
and you are going to get a water molecule.
So you can think of it as the oxygen
being the final acceptor of the electrons,
and oxygen likes to be doing oxid--
likes to oxidize things,
that's where the whole
word Oxidation comes from.
So here, (mumbles)
oxygen likes to be reduced.
It likes to hog electrons,
so this is oxygen is being reduced.
Oxygen, Oxygen reduced.
So if you just directly
transferred these electrons
from our NADH to the Oxygen,
it would release a lot of energy
but it would release so much energy
that you wouldn't be able
to capture most of it.
You wouldn't be able to use
it to actually do useful work,
and so the process of
Oxidative Phosphorylation
is all about doing this
at a series of steps
and we do it by
transferring these electrons
from one electron acceptor
to another electron acceptor,
and every time we do that,
we release some energy,
and then that energy can be,
in a more controlled way,
be used to actually do
work, and in this case,
that work is pumping hydrogen protons
across a membrane, and then
that gradient that forms
can actually be used to generate ATP,
so let's talk through
it a little bit more.
So we're gonna go, these electrons,
they're gonna be transferred,
and I won't go into all of the details,
this is to just give you a
high-level overview of it.
They're going to be transferred
to different acceptors
which then transfer it
to another acceptor,
so it might go to a Coenzyme,
Coenzyme Q, and a Cytochrome,
Cytochrome C, and it keeps
going to different things,
eventually getting to this
state right over here,
where those electrons can be accepted
by the oxygen
to actually form the
water, and the process,
every step of the way,
energy is being released.
Energy is being released,
and this energy, as we
will see in a second,
is being used to pump hydrogen protons
across a membrane, and we're
gonna use that gradient
to actually drive the production of ATP.
So let's think about
that a little bit more.
So let's zoom in on,
on a mitochondria.
So this is mitochondria.
Let's say that's our mitochondria,
and let me draw the inner membrane
and then, these folds
in the inner membrane,
the singular for them is crista.
If we're talking about plurals, cristae.
So we have these folds in the inner,
in the inner membrane right over here.
So just to be clear, what's going on,
this is the outer membrane,
outer membrane.
That is the inner
membrane, inner membrane.
The space between the outer
and the inner membrane,
the space right over here,
that is the intermembrane space.
Intermembrane,
membrane space.
And then the space inside
the inner membrane,
let me make that sure you
can read that space properly,
this space over here, this is the Matrix.
This is the Matrix, and
that is the location
of our Citric acid Cycle
or our Krebs Cycle,
and I can symbolize that
with this little cycle,
we have a cycle going on here.
And so that's where the bulk
of the NADH is being produced.
Now we also talked about
some other coenzymes.
In some books or classes,
you might hear about FAD
being reduced to FADH2,
which can then be oxidized
as part of Oxidative Phosphorylation.
Other times, well actually,
that's going to be attached
to an enzyme, and then that FADH2
is used to reduce
Coenzyme Q to produce QH2,
and then that participates
in Oxidative Phosphorylation,
so you could think about
either one of these.
I'll focus on QH2.
Well, why should we focus on NADH
because it's all a similar process?
FADH2 or QH2 enters a little bit later
down this process,
so they don't produce as much energy
but they still can be
used to help produce ATP,
but anyway, our Citric acid Cycle,
which we have shown in previous videos,
that occurring in the matrix,
and now let me do a little zoom in here,
let me do a zoom in.
So if I were to zoom in, let's say,
let me do this in a color that we can see,
so if I were to zoom in right over there,
let's show this fold
in the inner membrane,
and it's very, and let's make it clear
that this is, like all of these membranes,
these are all phospholipid bilayers,
so, let me draw,
let me do the same
color that I did in the,
the actual diagram.
So, we have...
all these, we have a
bilayer of phospholipids
and I'm clearly not drawing
any of this stuff to scale,
so, almost done.
All right, just to make it clear.
And you have these enzymes
that go across the phospholipid bilayer,
and these enzymes are,
and these protein complexes
are actually what facilitate
Oxidative Phosphorylation
and this chain of enzymes,
this chain of proteins, is
what we call the electron,
or what we call the
electron transport chain.
So we draw that.
So maybe this is one protein,
and I'm just drawing them
as kind of these abstract...
You could refer to the
electron transport chain as
these proteins or you could
view it as this process of
these electrons going from
one acceptor to another,
eventually making its way
all the way to the oxygen.
So that might be one protein,
this is another protein right over here.
I'll just do a couple,
and this is really about
a high-level overview,
and what's happening
is as the, and this is
just gonna be a very
high-level simplification of it,
as you have your, let's say initially,
your NADH comes in,
so your NADH comes in,
and it donates the
protons and the electrons
and then it become NAD+,
so it just became oxidized,
those electrons will go to an acceptor
which then gets transferred
to another acceptor
then get transferred to another acceptor,
and it goes through this
electron transport chain
and as that energy is released,
that energy is used to pump
hydrogen protons from the Matrix
so this side right over here,
the left side right over here,
this is the Matrix.
This is where our Citric
acid Cycle occurs,
so we have protons being pumped out,
so we have these protons being pumped out
as we release energy,
as we go from one electron acceptor
to another electron acceptor,
and so electrons are going
from higher energy states
and they're releasing
energy as they go down
this kind of a, towards more
and more electronegative things
and they feel more
comfortable with the water
than they feel, than
they felt with the NADH,
and by doing so, by these
electrons going down
that gradient, I guess you could say,
or maybe a better way, from going from a,
a higher energy state
to a lower energy state,
we are creating this proton gradient,
so the concentration of protons
on the right side of this membrane,
just to be clear where this is.
This space right over here,
this is right over there,
that's the intermembrane space
where the hydrogen proton
concentration is building up.
Now, this is stored
energy because this is a
electrochemical gradient,
all this positive charge,
they want to get away from each other,
they want to go to this less
positive Matrix right over here
and also, just you have
a higher concentration
of hydrogens and just natural diffusion.
They would want to go down
their concentration gradient
into the Matrix.
There's less of the protons here.
There's less of the protons in the Matrix
than there are
in the intermembrane space,
and so, that's the opportunity
to now take that energy
and produce ATP with them,
and the way that this
happens, the way this happens,
let me extend my membrane a little bit,
that's a different color,
so let me extend my membrane a little bit,
is using a protein
called ATP synthase.
ATP synthase is actually a
protein complex, I should say.
So ATP synthase, really an enzyme,
and ATP synthase goes across...
It's actually a fascinating,
fascinating molecule.
I'll show a better
diagram of it in a second,
but your ATP synthase
goes across the membrane,
it actually has a fairly
mechanical structure
where it has a bit of a housing
and it has an axle in the housing,
so it looks, maybe, something like this,
and it actually has something,
you can view this as a, as a thing
that maybe holds it together,
so it's going across the membrane,
I'll show a better
diagram of it in a second.
So then, of course, the
membrane continues on,
the membrane continues
on, and what happens is
it allows these hydrogen protons
to flow down their
electrochemical gradient,
so these hydrogen protons go down
and they actually cause the axle to spin,
and so maybe I'll draw it this way.
They actually cause the axle to spin
as they go
down their electrochemical gradient,
and as this axle spins,
this axle is not the smooth,
it's not like it's made
out of metal or something,
it's made out of amino
acids, so it's got this,
it's all bumpy and all the rest,
so it looks something like this,
and what happens is you have ADPs,
you have ADPs that get lodged in here,
so let's say that's an ADP,
and then a phosphate group,
and they have actually
three different sites
where this can happen,
so that's an ADP and a phosphate group,
and there's another site
that I'm not drawing,
but as this thing rotates,
it essentially keeps changing
the confirmation protein
and jams the phosphate group into the ADP
which takes energy and
locks them into place
to form the ATP.
When they form the ATP,
they no longer attach to the active site
and they let go.
So you have this,
actually, this mechanical motor,
you can view this almost like
a turbine, a water turbine.
The water goes through
it and then that energy
is used to generate electricity.
Here, hydrogen protons go down
their electrochemical gradient,
that rotary motion is then
used to jam phosphate groups
onto ADPs to form ATPs,
and so this is the actual
ATP production going on.
And to get a better appreciation
for what's going on,
this is going on in your body right now,
this is going on in my body,
otherwise I wouldn't be able to talk.
This is how I'm generating my energy.
This is a more accurate depiction
of ATP synthase right over here,
and based on this diagram,
this is our...
let me make sure I...
So this right over here,
I'm having trouble drawing on this,
let me see if I can...
So this part right over here,
this area right over there,
that's our intermembrane space.
This right over here is our,
this over here is our Matrix.
This membrane, this is
a phospholipid bilayer,
so if I wanted, I could draw
the bilayer of phospholipids
right over here,
and this is our inner membrane
or we could say this is a
fold in the inner membrane,
this could be on our crista,
and so the hydrogen protons, they build up
in the intermembrane space
because of the electron transport chain,
and then they flow down
their electrochemical gradient,
turn this rotor,
and then they cause the
creation of the ATPs over here,
so you have ADP
plus a phosphate group
and then you produce your ATP.
So this is fascinating,
this is going on in
the cells of your body,
this is going on as we speak.
It's not some abstract thing
that is somehow separate
from your reality.
This is what is making
your reality possible.
So hopefully, you get a
nice appreciation for this.
I mean, we spent a lot of time
talking about cellular respiration,
we spent a lot of time talking about,
OK, we can produce some ATPs directly
through glycolysis and
through the Citric acid Cycle,
but mostly, most of the energy
is because of the reduction
of these coenzymes
and especially, NAD to NADH,
and then in Oxidative Phosphorylation
and the electron transport chain,
we use the Oxidation of the NADH
to pump hydrogen protons from the Matrix
to the intermembrane space,
and then let them go back through,
through the ATP synthase
which jams the phosphate
into the ADP to produce the ATP,
which is our biological
currency of energy.